me and I didn't feel confident in myself
but even though I've lost that weight
I've still carried that with me so for
the Americans at home I was calculating
yeah 16 stone is 224 pounds you're 220
pounds 59 like nearly 16 Stone wow so
wow seriously I know how I fit so as
much as people used to say oh you look
good me personally for myself I didn't
feel that way um
I I was like that my whole life but I I
was just sick and tired of being unhappy
I'm like do you know this world is so
short yeah and if you can get to that
point without that then great bar me
personally it was just a massive thing I
couldn't get past it it's amazing
because a lot of the majority of people
they when they get that big they can't
go back it's a large percentage of
people that well
yeah I was at my heaviest I was 19 Stone
that's more more than 16 Stone
wow are you guys friends yeah yeah did
you guys meet each other you guys do it
together yeah did you lose it together
no I I was literally the the fat kid
that ate cake I was the food was my
comfort it was it was everything like
Matilda yeah and that's
and it was an everyday thing but in my
head in my mind I was Shifting the
weight but the reality of it as I wasn't
I wasn't motivated and there was nothing
to work toward and I lived with that for
most of my childhood I live with that
throughout my early adult years
um I I had children when I was young so
obviously after having children
um you've got the baby weight that
stayed on you and then you will have
areas of your body then that
um that you can't cover up yeah you know
that you can't hide
um and so that kind of led me to then
staying at home
um and then there's a cycle after that
um where you know you're at home you're
socially excluded from from from places
and people um and then you tend to put
yourself into a box or a self-hate then
um because whatever trauma that you
actually had which got you there starts
to manifest as you get older and when
you look at the people around you and
you look at how people respond to you
you're constantly battling yourself and
it is self and and for me I had to heal
first I had to First figure out what was
the trauma yeah where's the problem
um and with that you don't even know
where to begin because you don't know
what the problem is and then you have to
Soul search you have to look who you've
got around you you then have to look at
your parents
um how you grew up your school days
um and all of that you have to calculate
and sometimes you are the problem
sometimes the way that you've behaved is
a problem however the way that you've
behaved isn't necessarily because you've
wanted to be that way but you was trying
to be something that you was not in the
first instance so for me once I
discovered all of that
um and I and I shifted to to some weight
and got to a healthy weight I then chose
for me to have surgery that was that was
the gift to myself
so after I'd healed and I'd recognize
where the trauma came from and I dealt
with that trauma my gift to myself then
was to have surgery what kind of surgery
I had a tummy tuck good for you I've had
liposuction me too I've had my boobs
done I I had I had lipo so I did so and
tying into the whole thing because a lot
of people try to like [__] on me right
now because I got liposuction right
because I was just in such a bad place
you know why because I was reading
YouTube comments
everybody's just telling me this was in
like 2021 March I got it but I also was
fully transparent about it and I made a
full documentary good about it in Tokyo
and but at the time it was so crazy
because I was so like just constantly
being slammed because I wasn't like huge
I just had like a little in the in my
midsection and then
I was just like a man possessed and then
I just like yeah let's do it let's do it
pay pay pay whatever and then next thing
you know I'm laying on the [__]
surgery tail I'm like oh [__] like this
is gonna be crazy and then I woke up and
I was just like oh my God I can't
believe I went through with that that
you know it's the same for myself but
and you know what's you know what's so
crazy too given that because like I said
I'm not I'm not hiding it I don't care I
I tell everybody you know what put it on
my Tombstone like put it right there
here lies MLD you got liposuction what
an [__]
you know um
happy when I did it and then I learned a
lot of lessons along the way
so but even though now I get shamed why
for being a man that got liposuction
right but I don't care because you get
called lazy though that you were lazy oh
you everything this guy does this guy
has no discipline this guy this this guy
that I'm like have you seen the
business Empire that I run like I didn't
run that being lazy but all that aside
yeah I would rather personally I would
rather be shamed for getting liposuction
than being shamed for being overweight
and at this point in my life if they
because people are going to criticize
you no matter what and I did use it
because you know I wanted to create this
documentary
and it wanted the fat cells out of my
body and so
um I'm still I'm even here on the UK on
my trip I'm still exercising I still eat
clean yeah and I understand to uh is it
Alicia Alicia Alicia Alicia I'm so sorry
Malaysia as Alicia alluded to earlier
Alicia was correct when she said the
symptom is something going on inside you
and then Pam as well said that what was
going on inside of you is there is some
there's some trauma there's some things
so I think what Pearl said is absolutely
correct we can't glorify this because at
the end of the day what we're doing is
we're glorifying poor mental health yes
because it's we can't be glorifying that
kind of stuff because and you're
literally sending people off to an early
grave I'm a big fan of being alive
you know and it's so it's interesting
too that you guys like weren't hand
selected for this body positivity thing
I know I have no idea yeah that's like
the universe is coming together that's
pretty cool the the thing is there's a
perception
um when it comes to people that choose
to have elective surgery and that is
what I try in my day-to-day life try to
allow people to see that it's not about
just wanting to have surgery to get rid
but some people are not best gym
candidates I wasn't I mean I I'd spent
thousands of pounds on on personal
trainers on diet plans
um I was doing all sorts however what
happens is yes you might lose the weight
the weight will go down in my case I I
had a hernia I'd had three C-sections
um my stomach was protruding that's the
the reptile muscle in the middle was had
opened I needed to have muscle repair
and that cannot be fixed in the gym
right so when I was losing the weight in
fact I actually looked better when I was
bigger because I could hold my own when
I lost the weight everything dropped and
went down south yeah it looked worse
yeah to be fair
um so when I saw that it happened after
I'd lost all the weight well what do I
do now because the gym is not going to
help this yeah I need to have a tummy
tuck yeah I need to have muscle repair
so so knowing that I needed to have that
done there is there is a you know a
number of people out there why don't you
go to the gym well I did yeah for many
years and my biggest thing is too if
we're supposed to like enthusiastically
support people chopping off their
wieners and becoming women like you've
got to shut up about this other stuff
too like guys can I say something to
someone you know you gotta choose one
can I share something please can I just
remind you all that body positivity
isn't only like people with big big
black relatives it's about unable people
as well and people are born deformed
some people are born with disabilities
and I think body positivity is also
linked with that but the main the main
marketing component of body positivity
is towards women to say you can be obese
I just don't think we should celebrate
something that's a choice
you're celebrating it when you're
putting on the cover of magazines that's
a reward that's like a positive thing
when you're you're specifically giving
people Parts because they're plus size
when you're specifically trying to put
it out there make that the
representation of in the media
um and and it's interesting too because
earlier you said like um that you seem
to say like you couldn't lose the weight
is that what you were saying earlier yes
I couldn't but it's but it's like before
we the podcast starts
no don't get me wrong yeah
um hello I'm on your podcast I want to
have a good time you know I'm not at
home I don't need to be freaking old
healthy stuff but what I'm saying Okay
the reason I say that is just because
I'll hear people say that but then I
like watch what they eat and I'm like it
doesn't seem to happen do you know it's
just about representation it's it's
basically the little things from like
there's for example you can go to a
store you can't get certain things
um you can order something from online
you can't see you can't actually because
there's not the person wearing it you
can't see it
what I was actually going to say
something what I wanted to say is
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible